and we'll start with this the White
House is supporting and continuing a
threat to shut down much of the
government if President Trump does not
get five billion dollars from Congress
for his proposed border wall a shutdown
could happen on Friday December 21st
21st if Congress doesn't approve more
government funding Democrats say they
will not negotiate over the border wall
the budget fight was overshadowed over
the weekend by a court ruling declaring
the Affordable Care Act unconstitutional
Paula Reid is at the White House with
the latest Paula good morning good
morning Republican lawmakers have been
scrambling to try to avoid a shutdown
but say they have reached an impasse now
Congress has until midnight on Friday to
come up with some sort of deal to avoid
a shutdown but if they cannot dozens of
agencies will closed down and hundreds
of thousands of workers will be sent
home before the holiday without pay
we're gonna do whatever is necessary to
build the border wall White House senior
adviser Stephen Miller stood behind the
president's threat to shut down the
government if Congress doesn't grant
funding for the border wall and that
means if it comes to it absolutely this
is a very fundamental issue there are
not the votes for the wall in the house
or the Senate Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer said Democrats will not
budge on their opposition to the five
billion dollar project all he's gonna
get with his temper tantrum is a
shutdown he will not get a wall he's
urging mr. Trump to accept his party's
offer of 1.3 billion dollars for border
security
we need border security an offer that
was made to the president during last
week's contentious oval office meeting I
am proud to shut down the government for
border security if both sides can't
reach an agreement by Friday more than
420 thousand federal employees including
over 41,000 law enforcement officials
and up to 88 percent of Homeland
Security Department staff would be
working without pay during the holiday
season an additional 380 thousand
federal employees would be furloughed
what a crowd meanwhile over the weekend
the president applauded a decision by a
federal judge in Texas who ruled Obama
cares individual mandate is
unconstitutional and that the rest of
the law cannot survive without it the
president called
a great decision for the country if the
Republicans and the Democrats get
together we are going to end up with
incredible health care in his ruling the
judge said that the individual mandate
is unconstitutional because it no longer
carries a financial penalty Republicans
eliminated that last year but President
Obama took to Twitter to assure
Americans who use Obamacare that any
appeal on this ruling could take months
if not years viana yeah it's assumed to
go back to the Supreme Court but Paula
if the judge's ruling is upheld what
does that mean for the health care
industry as a whole
avianna this would have enormous
ramifications for Americans and the
health care industry it is estimated
that as many as 17 million Americans
could lose their insurance no different
components of the Act that could be in
jeopardy include Medicare Medicaid
pre-existing conditions and employee
sponsored insurance now according to a
2017 report a repeal could also increase
premiums by as much as 25% a group of
intervening states of course led by
Democrats promised to appeal this but
you know that could ultimately as you
said that would likely result in a
showdown at the Supreme Court now the
court has twice upheld the
constitutionality of Obamacare but we
have a new court with the additions of
justices Kavanaugh and courses this
could likely tilt the court to the right
but even the White House says right now
Obamacare remains the law of the land
yeah it's worth noting that the judge
didn't issue an immediate injunction
there but we'll have much more on this
conversation and what this means for
every American's health care going
forward in our next hour Paula thank you